un gardien de musée a ruiné ce tableau
en y dessinant des yeux c'est pas la
première fois qu'une oeuvre est dégradée
dans un musée je vais te raconter
l'histoire de trois oeuvres cette fois
très célèbre qui elles aussi ont été
dégradés la première histoire concerne
la joconde en 2009 une visiteuse du
louvre-lens une tasse de thé vide sur le
tableau de léonard de vinci heureusement
une vitre blindée protège l'oeuvre ce
qui brise la tasse la vitre est un peu
abîmée mais mona lisa n'a rien la
deuxième histoire concerne la liberté
guidant le peuple en 2013 une jeune
femme écrit une inscription étrange sur
le tableau de delacroix à eux 911 en
fait ça fait référence à une pétition en
ligne réclamant une enquête
véritablement indépendante sur les
attentats du 11 septembre même si bon la
jeune femme jugés pénalement
irresponsable ne fera jamais lien avec
la pétition l'inscription qui faisait
une trentaine de centimètres a
finalement été nettoyées facilement en
quelques heures la dernière histoire
concerne viry noirefontaine en 1993 un
homme donne des coups de marteau à
l'oeuvre de marcel duchamp le même homme
récidivera en 2006 écrire à cette fois
le mot dada sur le riz noir une démarche
totalement artistique selon l'auteur